[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Anne Gellinek
na der Kanzler dieser Tage auf der Welt
hinfährt der Überfall Russlands auf die
Ukraine reist mit Scholz ist inzwischen
bei der dritten und letzten Station
seiner Südamerika-Reise angekommen in
Brasilien dessen neuer Präsident Lola
das Silva hat ein sagen wir schwieriges
Verhältnis zur Ukraine wo wurde mir
silenski nannte er einen comedianten für
den man Zitat keinen Krieg führen solle
damit dieser im Fernsehen auftauchen
kann Munition für deutsche Panzer
liefern will Brasilien lieber nicht
Russland Sanktionen macht Lula auch
nicht mit daher versucht Scholz den
Schwerpunkt der Reise auf andere
wichtige Themen zu lenken wie den Schutz
des Regenwaldes und den Welthandel
Themen die dem deutschen Regierungschef
deutlich angenehmer sein dürften als die
ewige panzerdebatte zu Hause Weg
begleitet den Kanzler auf seiner Reise
dieser Gang ein Symbol Lula da Silva ist
wieder Präsident Brasilien ist wieder da
Olaf Scholz trifft Lula als erster
wichtiger westliche Regierungschef nach
dessen Rückkehr ins Amt gesprochen haben
die beiden schon oft doch diese Moment
ist besonders
symbolisch auch dies schienespräsident
lässt den Besuch des Bundeskanzlers
gestern dort beginnen wo das Land an die
Opfer seiner Militärdiktatur erinnert im
wiederaufgebauten Präsidentenpalast beim
Putsch 1973 bombardiert geht es dann um
die Zukunft beide Länder wir wollen
viele auf seinem Weg zu einem
nachhaltigen Bergbau gerne unterstützen
deshalb haben wir unsere
rohstoff-partnerschaft nicht nur
erneuert sondern ausgeweitet und auch
ergänzt eben um Aspekte der
Nachhaltigkeit deutsche Technik soll bei
abbauen und Weiterverarbeitung Umwelt
und klimaschonen etliche Vereinbarungen
werden auf der Reise getroffen etwa beim
Kupfer
wenn wir die Industrie transformieren
wollen wenn wir die Stromerzeugung
transformieren wollen zur co2-freiheit
dann brauchen wir Elektrizität dann
brauchen wir damit auch natürlich
großmenge an Kupfer für Windkraftanlagen
für Elektrofahrzeuge und deswegen ist
unser Interesse in Chile ein
nachhaltigen und wirklich auch
verantwortungsvollen Bergbau und eine
Weiterverarbeitung über die gesamte
Prozesskette zu etablieren besonders
begehrt Lithium der Bedarf explodiert
100 mal mehr bis 2050 noch ist
Deutschland hier von China abhängig
höchste Zeit aufzuholen
das ist für uns als deutsches
Unternehmen sehr schön zu hören dass wir
jetzt Gehör finden beim Kanzler und dass
er auch intensiv diese Bestrebungen von
uns unterstützt und vor Ort bei den
Behörden bei den Ministerien für uns
einsteht und dass da ein Umdenken
stattfindet es müssen wir das mit Leben
erfüllen ich schlage vor dass mir junge
Ingenieure Elektroingenieure
Maschinenbauingenieure von
Chile von Argentinen bei uns trainieren
damit doch noch die
idealen Werte die sie jetzt machen bei
solchen Verträgen dass die dann in die
Praxis umgesetzt werden viele hat
angekündigt auch dem von Scholz
vorangetriebene klima-club beitreten zu
wollen
ich danke für das Vertrauen in unser
Land in mich Teil ja Partner sein zu
dürfen im Kampf gegen die Klimakrise
in Brasilien geht es jetzt um den Erhalt
des Regenwalds im Amazonasgebiet um mehr
wirtschaftliche Zusammenarbeit in vielen
Bereichen und wohl auch um ehemals
deutsche Waffen und Munition für die
Ukraine die beiden haben viel zu bereden
und unser hauptstadtkorrespondent Klaus
Brodbeck ist uns jetzt live aus Brasilia
zugeschaltet Klaus guten Abend wie sehr
hat die deutsche Innenpolitik eigentlich
diese Reise von Scholz überschattet
sie hat sich auf jeden Fall sehr
beschäftigt das hat in jeder
pressekonferenzfragende nachgegeben in
jedem Hintergrundgespräch das Holz mit
Journalisten hatte natürlich auch in
vielen Gesprächen am Rande Scholz hat
immer gesagt er versuche die europäische
die westliche Perspektive auf diesen
Konflikt den Ländern den Regierungen
hier in der Region nahezubringen weil
die eben dann doch nicht nur wegen der
großen Entfernung ganz anders drauf
gucken für die ist das ein europäische
Konflikt wichtig war natürlich auch die
Frage gibt es Waffen aus Lateinamerika
für die Ukraine die argentinische
Präsident hat das ganz klar für nein hat
gesagt wir werden nichts schicken in
keinen Konflikt auch nicht in denen der
Ukraine der chilenische gestern sagte
dann schon naja bienenräume könnte man
sich vorstellen und man selbst kann sich
irgendwie nicht vorstellen dass Scholz
und Luna darüber nicht reden mit welchem
Ergebnis das muss man sehen
es geht ja bei dieser Reise auch um
wertvolle Rohstoffe wie Lithium
inwieweit wird es Deutschland gelingen
sich hier gegen Konkurrenten wie China
die schon lange da sind durchzusetzen
experten sagen da ist es fünf nach zwölf
Scholz würde sagen wir waren zu lange
etapete haben nicht im Rohstoffgeschäft
mitgemischt haben das andere machen
lassen Tatsache ist Chile chinesische
Unternehmen haben in Chile und anderen
Ländern sehr sehr langfristige Verträge
die bis zum Ende des Jahrzehnts laufen
und erst dann wieder ausgeschrieben
werden da müssen die deutschen rein und
Sie müssen eben etwas anderem rein als
nur zu sagen wir transportieren die
Rohstoffe ab und verdienen das Geld und
ihr habt nichts davon deswegen versucht
man allen Ländern hier ich mag
schmackhaft zu machen ist attraktiv zu
machen Wertschöpfung im Land zu lassen
so dass hier auch Arbeitsplätze
entstehen bewiesen eingenommen werden
aber es bleibt ein langer Prozess
wichtig ist er trotzdem weil bis zum
Jahr 2050 wird sich der Bedarf an
Lithium weltweit verhundertfachen also
da muss man das getan werden
vielen Dank Klaus Brodbeck war das live
von der kanzlerreise nach Brasilien
vielen Dank dorthin
während Kanzler Scholz also versucht
sich in Südamerika auf Außenpolitik zu
konzentrieren tut wohl Leute mir
selensky in der Ukraine so als habe er
nicht mitbekommen wie schwierig die
Entscheidung für die deutsche Regierung
war Kampfpanzer ins Kriegsgebiet zu
liefern und fordert sogleich Kampfjets
sie lensky interessiert sich nicht für
deutsche Innenpolitik der Mann hat
andere Sorgen die Situation an der Front
ist schwierig es scheint als schafften
es die Ukraine nicht die russische Armee
weiter zurückzudrängen die Ukraine müsse
die Ereignisse beschleunigen sagt sie
lensky und meint Waffenlieferung Andreas
kühnerst berichtet
ich lag im Bett sagt Svetlana borisovna
und zittert immer noch die Kraft die
mich plötzlich packte war so stark dass
ich bis in die Küche flog
keine Ahnung warum ich noch lebe
in welchem Stock sie wohnte im zweiten
Halle Fenster flogen raus Gott weiß was
uns da getroffen hat
es hat wieder ein Wohnhaus getroffen
wieder in rakiff ein Nachbar tot drei
verletzt Tag 341 des Krieges
die russischen Truppen intensivieren
ihre Angriffe sagt Präsident selensky
der heute mit Dänemarks
Ministerpräsidentin in mikulajev ist die
Ukraine verliert täglich Menschenleben
Infrastruktur Ressourcen die Ukraine
bitte täglich um Hilfe
herzlich willkommen
er Verteidigungsminister wird bei seinem
Antrittsbesuch beim Einsatz
Führungskommando gefragt ob Deutschland
nun auch Kampfjets liefert dabei hat der
Bundeskanzler bereits nein gesagt ich
habe etwas gelernt in der Politik dass
ich auf hypothetische Fragen nicht
antworte egal ob sie meine Person oder
tatsächliche Situation betreffen und das
gilt für diese Frage auch und im übrigen
hat der Bundeskanzler dazu meines
Wissens alles gesagt was zu sagen ist
aber auch der Bundeskanzler wird wieder
nach Kampfjets gefragt dabei hat er
bereits nein gesagt wir haben auch z.B
solche unsinnigen ansinn wie
Bodentruppen abgelehnt und deshalb noch
mal es ist dazu jetzt wirklich nicht
alles gesagt auch von mir die Frage nach
dem Grund der Vorsicht von Scholz die
Frage ob Präsident Putin dem deutschen
Kanzler je gedroht hat hat Scholz mit
Nein beantwortet kein kleines Detail
weil ein anderer ein ehemaliger
Regierungschef heute enthüllt die hat
mir einmal gedroht und gesagt du weißt
Boris ich will dir nicht weh tun aber
eine Rakete würde nur eine Minute
brauchen oder so ähnlich
was Johnson sagt ist nicht wahr es ist
eine Lüge
in Russland gibt es keine Diskussionen
über den Einsatz von Kampfjets das
Verteidigungsministerium veröffentlicht
heute diese aufwendig gedrehten Bilder
die die Zerstörung einer ukrainischen
Militäreinrichtung zeigen sollen
die Situation ist sehr schwierig bachmut
wohl da und andere Gebete sind ständigen
russischen Angriffen ausgesetzt
ständigen versuchen unsere Verteidigung
zu durchbrechen
in Moskau wächst die Wut darüber dass
der Westen die Hilferufe der Ukraine
erhört buchstäblich jeden Tag wird im
Fernsehen mit Atomkrieg gedruckt werden
wir gewinnen 100 Prozent wo überall
überall nicht nur in der Ukraine überall
die Bundesregierung hat zu weiteren
Waffenlieferungen hat zu Kampfjets alles
gesagt aber sie wird wieder und wieder
gefragt werden
nicht nur Boris Pistorius ganz Europa
zählt gerade seine Panzer wer hat wie
viel welchen Typs in welchem Zustand
symptomatisch dabei viele europäische
Armeen haben ihre Kampfpanzer längst
ausgemustert weil man sich nicht
vorstellen konnte dass sie nach Ende des
Kalten Kriegs überhaupt noch mal
gebraucht würden so wie in Belgien zum
Beispiel zwischen 2015 und 2017
verkaufte die belgische Regierung
dutzende Leopard 1 Panzer an einen
Waffenhändler der sie einlagerte jetzt
würde die belgische Regierung sie gern
als Hilfe für die Ukraine zurückkaufen
doch die marodengeräte sind mittlerweile
unbezahlbar Florian Neuhann mit einer
Geschichte über Angebot und Nachfrage
dieser Mann hat wonach fast ganz Europa
gerade dringend sucht und zwar gleich
zwei Hallen voll Tournee im Westen
Belgiens der Waffenhändler Freddy
verslois führt uns durch sein Lager
27000 Quadratmeter groß hunderte
Militärfahrzeuge warten hier auf Kunden
darunter allein 50 Leopard 1 Kampfpanzer
die Leppard
in großen Mengen dazu die Fahrgestelle
die bergungsfahrzeuge und natürlich alle
mit Kanone 105 mm
es ist ein seltener Einblick in eine
üblicherweise verschwiegende Welt und
eine Geschichte darüber wie Westeuropa
seinen militärbedarf über die Jahre
immer wieder anders eingeschätzt hat
etwa beim Leopard Panzer noch bis in die
90er Jahre besaß er dann das kleine
Belgien weit über 300 davon und
verkaufte sie alle samt der Kalte Krieg
schien zu Ende das Geld wurde anderswo
gebraucht
also der Fall Belgien ist eigentlich
typisch für die Europäer in dieser Zeit
damals hat man ja wirklich gedacht dass
man von Freunden umgeben ist und dass
der Einsatz von Militär völlig anders
aussehen würde wie im Kalten Krieg wo
wollte man 2001 auch Panzer einsetzen
und so landeten belgische Panzer in
Südamerika in Griechenland oder eben bei
Waffenhändler Freddy versleus der heute
mit ansieht wie die belgische Regierung
unter Druck steht sich der
panzerkoalition für die Ukraine
anzuschließen und wie sie sich fragen
lassen muss warum sie seine Panzer nicht
fix zurückkauft
wir haben das Unternehmen gefragt ob man
diese Panzer wieder im Stand setzen
können mit dem angebotenen Preis hätten
sie extreme Gewinne gemacht bis zu
500.000 € für Panzer die wir mal für
15.000 verkauft haben
aus diesem Krieg der Waffenhändler gibt
an der habe damals mehr gezahlt als die
Ministerin sagen was er heute verlange
sei Markt üblich und dann ist der
panzerbesitzer noch schnell
demonstrieren das mindestens einer
seiner Leoparden noch fährt in wenigen
Monaten könnten sie sagt er fit gemacht
werden für einen Einsatz auch in der
Ukraine
sie zu kaufen als sie auf dem Markt
waren jetzt gibt es unglücklicherweise
einen Krieg und deshalb Nachfrage das
ist mein Geschäftsmodell ich kaufe ich
verkaufe ist es gut es ist ein Business
wie jedes andere
vielleicht nicht wie jedes andere aber
auch bei Panzern gilt wohl das Gesetz
von Angebot und Nachfrage
und im heutigen Journal Update gibt es
noch ein Interview mit dem SPD Urgestein
und Bundestagsabgeordneten Axel Schäfer
über die Partei Panzer und Flugzeuge
und hier geht es jetzt weiter mit
Nachrichten von Gundula Gause und die
beginnen mit den Unruhen im Nahen Osten
und heute ist US-Außenminister blinken
dort zu einem lang geplanten Besuch
eingetroffen dabei hat er in Israel alle
Seiten zu Mäßigung aufgerufen nach den
jüngsten Gewaltakten forderte er die
zunehmende Gewalt zu stoppen auch
gegenüber Israels Premier Netanjahu
warnte er vor Vergeltung es sei
jedermanns Verantwortung Schritte zu
ergreifen um Spannungen abzubauen statt
sie zu führen als Reaktion auf die
Tötung von sieben Israelis vergangenen
Freitag hat die israelische Regierung
die Häuser von Palästinensern die ohne
Baugenehmigung in Ost Jerusalem gebaut
worden waren zerstören lassen
im Nordwesten Pakistans sind in einer
Moschee bei einem Selbstmordanschlag
mindestens 61 Menschen getötet worden
die Explosion ereignete sich während des
mittagsgebetes weitere Opfer werden
unter den Trümmern vermutet mehr als 150
Gläubige wurden verletzt die Behörden
schreiben den Anschlag islamistischen
Terrorgruppen zu noch hat sich niemand
dazu bekannt in ganz Pakistan wurden die
Sicherheitskräfte in höchste
Alarmbereitschaft versetzt
auch nach dem Ende des Solidarpaktes zum
Aufbau Ost darf der Bund weiter den
Solidaritätszuschlag erheben der
Bundesfinanzhof urteilte der sogenannte
Soli ist nicht verfassungswidrig und wie
ist die Klage eines bayerischen Ehepaars
ab die sehen den Gleichheitsgrundsatz
verletzt da der Soli nur noch von
Unternehmern und gut verdienen gezahlt
werden muss und sie halten sich eine
Verfassungsbeschwerde offen 11
Milliarden Euro hatte der Bund 2021
darüber eingenommen
das CDU-Präsidium hat dem früheren
verfassungsschutzpräsidenten Hans-Georg
Maaßen einstimmig ein Ultimatum zum
Austritt aus der parteigesetzt falls er
bis Sonntag 5 Februar 12 Uhr nicht
ausgetreten sei solle der Bundesvorstand
der CDU ein Ausschlussverfahren
einleiten immer wieder Gebrauche Maßen
Sprache aus dem Milieu der Antisemiten
und verschwörungsideologen Maßen wie es
gegenüber der Welt die Vorwürfe zurück
und will offenbar an seiner
CDU-Mitgliedschaft festhalten
die Weltgesundheitsorganisation stuft
die corona-pandemie weiterhin als
globalen Notfall ein die Lage sei zwar
mittlerweile weltweit viel besser aber
in den vergangenen acht Wochen sein
mindestens 170.000 Menschen weltweit mit
dem Virus gestorben unterdessen hat
Bundesgesundheitsminister Lauterbach
erneut Fehler in der deutschen
corona-politik benannt die Schulen und
die Kitas so lange geschlossen zu halten
das war im Nachhinein ein Fehler auf der
anderen Seite ist es so damals wurde das
aber von den Wissenschaftlern die die
Bundesregierung beraten haben angeraten
heute vor 90 Jahren ernannte der
damalige Reichspräsident von Hindenburg
Adolf Hitler zum Reichskanzler Hitler
machte sich ans Werk und schaltete die
demokratischen Organe der Weimarer
Republik Stück für Stück aus
Demokratie kann schnell zu Ende sein mit
dieser Mahnung will die Stadt Leipzig
heute Abend des Jahrestags gedenken und
mit viel Licht gegen das Dunkel von
Terror Hass und Gewalt demonstrieren
Anja Chalet über die Aktion Leipzig
leuchtet
Leipzig leuchtet an diesem Abend für
Demokratie und Menschenrechte
einzustehen schließen sich über den
Innenstadtring mehrere tausend Bürger
zusammen viele Schirme erleuchtet mit
Taschenlampen und Handys auf der
demo-route vom Herbst 89 aufgerufen hat
ein breites demokratisches Bündnis der
Stadtgesellschaft
und für Demokratie das Leipzig eben also
viele demokratische Kräfte hat dass die
im in der Mehrzahl sind und dass wir
nicht hier rechten Kräften die Straße
überlassen ich sehe die Gefahr dort wo
Menschen Verschwörungstheorien
verbreiten wo Menschen verkürzte und
einfache Antworten geben und wo Menschen
behaupten wir würden gar keine
Demokratie haben möchte auch noch mal
darauf aufmerksam machen dass auch junge
Leute sich an der Demokratie beteilen
sollen das ist nicht vergessen wird
Demokratie ist kein Selbstläufer dafür
muss man kämpfen und sichtbar werden
auch auf der Straße und gerade hier in
Sachsen das weiß auch der sächsische
Ministerpräsident
die Menschen haben sich aufgemacht und
zwar aus der Zivilgesellschaft das ist
ja das Besondere was in Leipzig immer
wieder beeindruckt und was hier so
gelebt wird und wir sollten daran
erinnern dass wir für unsere Demokratie
kämpfen müssen es gibt Dinge die sind so
wichtig die sind so universell und dafür
treten wir über Parteigrenzen hinweg ein
nie darf sich wiederholen was vor genau
90 Jahren geschehen ist dafür
demonstrieren sie hier diese Abend ist
auch eine Mahnung an den 30 januar 1933
als mit der Machtübernahme der
Nationalsozialisten das dunkelste
Kapitel deutscher Geschichte begann und
dem Holocaust und einem Weltkrieg endete
Leipzigs damaliger Oberbürgermeister
Karl Friedrich Görler trat als Protest
gegen die Nazis 1937 zurück und wurde
später als einer der Hitler Attentäter
hingerichtet wäre den Anfängen das sagt
Gisela Kallenbach die 1989 zu den
mutigen Frauen und Männern gehörte die
mit ihrem Protest den Montagsdemos die
DDR und dann die Mauer zur Fall brachten
leider auch in Leipzig seit Monaten
demonstrierende die
mitverschwörungsmythen die mit er Hass
und
spaltungstendenzen in der Gesellschaft
agieren und deshalb müssen wir anderen
die wir vielleicht bisher geschwiegen
haben auch laut werden
5000 Menschen haben Leipzig an diesem
Abend zum Leuchten gebracht
und hier geht es nochmal weiter mit
Nachrichten aus der Wirtschaft und mit
Gundula die Windkraft in Deutschland
soll deutlich schneller ausgebaut werden
das Bundeskabinett hat zur Umsetzung
neuer EU-Regeln Vorgaben auf den Weg
gebracht mit denen auch Stromleitungen
Solaranlagen und Wärmepumpen zügiger
gebaut werden sollen um
Genehmigungsverfahren zu beschleunigen
sollen damit in Eignungsgebieten
vielfachprüfungen auf
Umweltverträglichkeit und Artenschutz
entfallen harte Kritik kommt bereits von
Umweltschützern
zum Jahresende haben die Verbraucher
überraschend deutlich gespart und sich
bei Käufen zurückgehalten der Rückgang
des privaten Verbrauchs gilt als
Hauptursache für das überraschende minus
beim Bruttoinlandsprodukt im vierten
Quartal 22 Valerie Haller droht nun
tatsächlich eine winterresession kann
gut sein aber dann wird es vermutlich
eine wie es so schön heißt technische
Rezession das heißt also zwei Quartale
infolge eine schrumpfende Wirtschaft
bedeutet aber nicht automatisch ein
konjunkturabsturz volkswirte rechnen
eher mit einer leichten Abkühlung und
das hat verschiedene Gründe die
Industrieproduktion stabilisiert sich
der Außenhandel läuft wieder besser und
die Inflation schwächt sich gerade
allmählich ab sie war ja auch der
Hauptgrund für das Minus am Jahresende
denn weil die Preise so stark gestiegen
waren für Strom Gas Lebensmittel
beispielsweise ging der Konsum zurück
der Konjunktur fehlte damit eine
wichtige Stütze aktuell also
Schrumpfkurs übers Jahr gesehen gesehen
hat sich die Konjunktur aber noch ganz
gut geschlagen unterm Strich steht für
2022 ein Wachstum von 1,8% besser als
man angesichts der multiplen Krise hätte
vermuten können zuletzt war
Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck ja auch
zuversichtlich es gäbe keine Tiefe
Konjunkturdelle in diesem Jahr das
stimmt davon gehen ja auch viele
Volkswirte aus weil es einige Mut
machende Konjunktursignale gibt eine
Entspannung bei den Energiepreisen und
eine stärkere chinesische Wirtschaft
beispielsweise aber klar langfristige
Prognosen sind immer schwierig und die
aktuellen Risiken riesig dazu gehören
eine Eskalation des russischen Krieges
gegen die Ukraine und aber auch die
Inflation die sich ja zwar gerade besser
aber auch in diesem Jahr Realeinkommen
belassen dürfte vielen Dank weil Arena
Frankfurt
zum Sport Dänemark ist gestern Abend im
Handball historisches geglückt zum
dritten Mal in Folge sind die
Skandinavier Weltmeister geworden mit
einem 34 zu 29 Finalsieg über
Olympiasieger Frankreich als
wertvollster Spieler des Turniers wurde
anschließend der dänemattias Kitzel
gewählt und auch zwei deutsche Spieler
schafften es ins Allstar Team Andreas
Wolf als bester Torhüter und der
22-Jährige Juri Knorr als bester
Youngster dieser Handball WM
die frisch gekürten deutschen Hockey
Weltmeister sind nach ihrem Triumph im
Final Krimi und einer langen feiernacht
in Indien vor drei Stunden wieder in
Deutschland gelandet sichtlich glücklich
über Goldmedaillen und den WM-Pokal
gestern hatten die Hockey Herren in
einem dramatischen Panel Tisch schießen
gegen Titelverteidiger Belgien den
ersten Weltmeistertitel seit 17 Jahren
gewonnen
nach drei Jahren Pandemie versuchen die
Museen ihre Besucher zurückzuholen und
das ist angesichts knapper Kassen in
vielen Privathaushalten gar nicht so
einfach das NRW Forum in Düsseldorf hat
es geschafft 50.000 vorwiegend junge
Leute anzulocken mit Graffiti Designer
Spielzeug und Vinyl aus Street Art Bund
gemixt das alles in einer coolen
Ausstellung in der Menschen die deutlich
jünger sind als ich vor allem das hier
machen ein selfie mit Kunst sollte
Färber hat sich das angesehen
alles knallbunt und überwältigend in
dieser Ausstellung zückt jeder
irgendwann sein Handy
wonderwalls zeigt Streetart und
Popkultur
ein Publikumsrenner 50.000 Menschen sind
bisher gekommen fast jeder dritte sehr
jung im ausbildungsalter
das ist eine Ausstellung die einfach
bunt farbenfroh ist die einfach Spaß
macht und einfach weil gerade in der
jungen Zielgruppe sehr erfolgreich ist
wenn man sich da selbst inszenieren kann
weil man tolle Bilder machen kann sie
ist sehr Instagram aber
Kunst mal niedrigschwellig und vor allem
viel davon 2000 Ausstellungsobjekte gibt
es alle hat der Unternehmer Selim warol
gesammelt hier hängt der echte Banksy
neben warols eigenem Kinderspielzeug
dass er selbst künstlerisch
weiterverarbeitet hat das Spielzeug war
für mich der Anfang des sammels der
Anfang der Popkultur und natürlich auch
für viele wie viele andere auch das
Leben dass wir gerne natürlich auch in
die Länge ziehen ne wenn wir länger
lernen Kind zu bleiben glaube ich lösen
wir viele Probleme auch einfacher viele
hier sind noch gar nicht so weit weg von
der eigenen Kindheit für unter
18-Jährige ist der Eintritt frei und die
Social Media Generation findet den Weg
in die Ausstellung ich bin durch darauf
aufmerksam geworden und dann haben wir
jetzt ein bisschen geguckt okay da ging
ganz viele Leute ja wir haben ganz gute
Bilder gemacht für Instagram ähm die wir
hochladen können eine Ausstellung geht
viral und das geplant das NRW Forum
betreibt auch einen eigenen tiktok Kanal
da wird schon meine Museum tanzt vor Ort
präsentiert sich wonderwalls mit immer
neuen Perspektiven
ich glaube dass jedes Museum natürlich
auch eine starke Präsenz auf Social
Media haben sollte aber auch in der
Ausstellungsgestaltung glaube ich muss
man einfach darauf achten dass man
szenisch arbeitet dass man dramaturgisch
arbeitet das kann man auch mit Caspar
David Friedrich Friedrich einfach nur
Bilder an die Wand hängen reicht heute
nicht mehr wenn sie hängen sind sie
originell angeordnet
Ausstellungen sollen den Leuten zwei
drei Stunden Erlebnis bieten die Idee
hier und es gelingt viele zu erreichen
Street Art für alle
irgendwie ist es ein Bezug zur Neuzeit
und zur Jugend
die mich mit 71 Jahren dann auch ein
bisschen ja beflügelt
wonderwalls macht vielen Spaß und sieht
auch Menschen ins Museum die selten dort
sind
und hier geht es jetzt weiter mit dem
montagskino und dem Thriller Songbird
überleben hat einen Preis gedreht im
gespenstisch leeren Los Angeles im
ersten corona-lockdown mit Demi Moor und
anderen Hollywoodstars
und direkt danach um 23:35 Uhr meldet
sich Wulff schmiese mit unserem heute
journal Update und beiden gibt es morgen
wieder in einen schönen Abend und
tschüss
[Musik]